hello everyone
and welcome to rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
and today we have a nice show we're
going to be doing like we always
try to do lately is uh we do extinction
first
then we do a little bit of physics and
then we're going to
get into the questions and comments that
people made
since last time and so let's start
with extinction and
extinction topics there are many
subjects related to extinction a lot of
people
like to go along the lines of politics
there everybody's an expert in politics
because it depends on
whether it's um your opinion your
recommendation what you think
how you think the world should be run
that sort of thing we're not so
interested in that here at least uh we
try to concentrate more on
the mechanism of extinction how it's
going to happen okay
okay so let's start with uh extinction
and here we have a lady i'll start with
a little article that came out
and and she says
tracy stone manning president joe
biden's
nominee to lead the bureau of land
management
argued that americans need to have fewer
children
and called american kids environmental
hazards
my god does he really believe this we
must consume less and more importantly
we must breed fewer consuming humans
and one lady that they quote in that
article
not her but someone else said it would
be my third baby but there's not
a population problem here like in africa
or
india and besides smart people like bob
and me
should be the people having kids
[Laughter]
okay uh should we have fewer kids maybe
maybe they should do the um what is it
uh
like the chinese did you know the one
child per family
rule uh you can't have more than one kid
is that what we should do maybe
you know just put a law there that if
you have two kids we gotta kill the
second one or
put you in jail or find year or whatever
[Laughter]
okay uh another issue related to
extinction a little more related to
extinction
i guess this is michio kaku
and he uh he's a futurollah
just now he uh he tries to tell us what
the future
looks like see all these people are into
predictions once you study
math uh mathematical physics
then you become an astrologer that's the
next step you make a lot of money just
making predictions
and he quotes uh sagan carl sagan
jeff bezos and elon musk and he says for
carl sagan
uh that one day carl sagan told him this
he says an asteroid will hit us one day
we have to make humans a two planet
species
what was sagan talking about well he was
talking about you know
uh if we happen to screw up this planet
uh maybe world war three or
we pollute it or whatever thing uh well
then we have this other
planet where consciousness
can continue living intelligence and
sometimes i wonder how much intelligence
these people really have
jeff bezos he says we have to make the
earth a grand park
okay we should relocate all polluting
industries to space or to the moon and
this should be just a garden
okay um is that
ever going to materialize is that ever
going to happen we're going to move all
the
heavy industry all the polluting
industry yeah no problem you want wanna
pollute go go to the moon we'll pollute
the whole moon after all it's just a
stone out there you know we just gotta
transfer all the production over there
and here we live
i guess doing services all day long
robots serving us
great life huh i think these people
uh think a little too much or maybe
they're not enough i guess
then elon musk he's the spacex uh
project manager i guess you could say he
wants to
create a multi-planet species we should
go to
several planets and um
he wants to ship one million passengers
to mars
one million people you know like
several trips little by little when we
populate
at least a region of mars we'll have a
million people there
hopefully self-sustaining which is what
he's thinking about
okay uh and here's a little more detail
of what
um what elon musk is proposing
a second here this is what he's
proposing he's saying multi-planet
species and safe space-faring
civilization we're going to be
floating in space you know going all
along our future is in space the final
frontier
you know ensure continuance of
consciousness
okay that way we guarantee that
conscience consciousness
will not die okay
is it a problem if it does don't you
think that even if consciousness
dies here on earth there's going to be
some other planet out there in the
middle of nowhere
that also creates consciousness just
like the earth did here maybe there is a
planet somewhere out there already
far away probably okay so uh the fact
that consciousness
dies here on earth and that we didn't
get to go to the moon or to mars or
anywhere and then the someone turns the
light out
on the earth is that a problem
i mean i think you should worry about
yourself
okay and not have these uh idealistic
things for
all of humanity and people take
decisions for all of humanity here
he wants to put a self-sustaining city
on mars
if ships from earth stop coming for
example
world war iii right that's what these
people are thinking
can the city sustain itself okay and it
must happen
before world war three because if we do
it
i mean if world war three happens first
is there any chance whatsoever that we
can create a colony on mars
so there's uh he's suggesting that we
should have this
rush to hurry it up before that world
war three comes around
okay i guess people are fearing that
that
will happen uh
i guess if you ask a lot of people out
there do a poll or whatever
i'm sure a lot of people will say that
they think it's
very possible now what percentage i
don't know they have that doomsday clock
there and they keep moving it back and
forth
depending on you know what's going on in
the world sometimes they move it closer
to 12 o'clock
sometimes closer to 10 o'clock you know
it goes back and forth
that hand on the clock how close are we
to 12 o'clock
meaning third world world war three and
will that be the demise of man if
we go you know if we have a war of that
nature where we
throw the news the bio weapons you know
we talked about that a little bit the
other day uh
if we throw the nukes if someone presses
that red button will that be the end of
man
okay or will someone survive and restart
the
world again okay keep that question in
mind okay
we'll see if we can address that okay uh
phil says
and again here we have the political
aspect
of extinction bill doesn't know and
doesn't believe about the existence of
great powers like the financial credit
elite and zionism in christian catholic
apostolic and islam and blah blah blah
he doesn't know and doesn't believe that
the world politics are under
great under these great powers and he
knows and he believes that the state and
the state governments
are in charge
well the first thing we have to do
is put in the right context
belief is not a part of science okay
belief is part of religion so
irrespective of what i believe
it's got nothing to do with science
especially in this case with extinction
which is the mechanism of extinction
okay
so uh whether i believe in this or that
doesn't matter the first thing we have
to
point out is this
give me a second let him do it
oh i see what happened give me a second
here put it behind the other one
okay um this this is a scientific
method okay what is science rational
explanations and where
in the scientific method which goes
under that step one step two step three
where do you find belief okay in
in the scientific method we make
assumptions
and then we build the theory on those
assumptions
so you can make an assumption that
zionism is out there and that
uh catholic church is doing something
that islam is doing whatever
and you can make any assumption and then
build your theory upon that so that we
can understand what's going through your
mind we can understand your theory
but just to say that oh bill doesn't
believe
well you haven't said anything you know
it does
we don't know what you're talking about
uh what is the conclusion what is your
theory
you know that's what we wish to know or
understand
and so you know without that you have
nothing at least for this channel
you know you really have to try to
concentrate on science
and not just say well he believes in
this and believes in that
you know we all have beliefs and beliefs
play
no role whatsoever in science so get the
word belief out of your mouth
never use it again not here okay unless
you're
saying well the religious folk will
leave that's right you can say something
like that you know
but not not in the context of science
okay don't bring the word believe
okay another issue someone raised uh
fella says uh both people in a trade are
buyers and sellers
uh because i talked about the fact that
well i'll get into that in a second but
essentially
i put the other day that you have sever
three situations you have the
uh buyer buyer buyer seller and seller
seller
okay and that's what he's addressing and
i'm saying that seller seller is the
only one that's capitalism
buyer seller is communism
and buyer buyer is uh
leisure uh unemployment
uh mana from heaven
okay so that's the context in which i
put these
two words buyer and seller and he's
addressing that he said both people
in a trade are buyers and sellers well
he's just repeating the party line of
every
what everybody out there thinks or or
the way they look at these two words
okay he hasn't put anything new in fact
that i don't think he understood what i
said
at all okay if you had a boat and i have
money and we trade them and i bought
abode by selling you money and you
bought money by selling me a boat
yeah in other words he he said the same
thing that everybody else says
so he didn't understand squat okay
and but i'm going to the next part the
transaction is capitalist as long as it
is voluntary meaning
no force or coercion was used
you needn't you you needing food to
survive doesn't count as
involuntary because that is forced onto
you by nature not humans
okay so yeah again i don't think this
fellow understood anything
what i said so let me repeat it okay
here it is
okay that's the situation you have um
these these three different situations
one is where you have a buyer and a
seller
okay buyer in the seller that's known as
communism
it's not known as capitalism it's known
as communism why because
we have to look at what the buyer is
doing here okay
if you just look at the buyer you don't
know uh
if he's giving something in in exchange
and i'll get to that in a second okay
uh but here are the three categories
essentially yours
three situations then you have the buyer
buyer the guy who receives
mana from heaven he's served by robots
nobody works on planet earth there's not
even a government
uh there's no military you're just
receiving stuff free from who knows what
maybe the
robots are working the land uh if jeff
bezos has his way they're working in
mars or in
on the moon and they're bringing the
stuff to you from over there you know
grapes and whatever they
are planting and harvesting up there and
they bring them over here
all done by robots and all we do all 8
billion 9 billion 10 billion
of us however many we are at the time
that this happens
we all receive and we all receive all
this free stuff from heaven
so we're all buyers we're not giving
anything in exchange
okay and then of course you have the
capitalist which is the true capitalist
which is a seller seller
there are no buyers in capitalism there
are only sellers
okay and you say bill what the hell are
you talking about
okay so let's find out what i'm talking
about let's define these terms so
so that we can use them consistently
i'll show you what i'm referring to
okay a little more detail than the other
day
seller what is a seller this is out of
the dictionary no no special word here
okay
but i'm gonna cut it short i'm gonna cut
it
uh where i should cut it or where i
think it should be cut
okay a person who sells okay
gives no inkling of anything else
whether he's receiving anything in
return it just sells i'm giving
something away
okay for now just bear with me okay
now we look up sell it says to transfer
goods or render services
and then they have that little piece
saying you know saying
in exchange for money or you can put
anything in there
in exchange for something okay and so
that's where we have a problem
uh seller uh should we stop at the
just gives away and
not talk about what he receives in
exchange seller just gives
okay that's that's my proposal i'm
saying he's just a giver
okay what is a buyer under this proposal
well buyer is a person who abides so we
look up the word
which means receives we look up the word
by okay
it says to acquire the possession of or
the right to
and then they add you know by paying or
promising to pay an equivalent
especially in money
purchase blah blah blah and i'm saying
we should take that
last part out what's enclosed in green
there
i think we should say buyers someone who
receives so one is
a giver the other one is a receiver now
uh you have situations like you know
someone
gives and doesn't receive we call it
donation or donator
donor okay and if he takes without
giving we caught stealing okay
so we have all these nuances in between
humans because this is all human stuff
you know uh
the rest of the animal kingdom typically
doesn't do
trade you know they do stealing i've
seen um
hyenas take away from cheetahs and from
other lesser animals weaker animals
and they just go in there and take
whatever they think they can get so
they do steal there is stealing out
there okay in the
wild kingdom but in general that's the
these are the situations what am i
talking about well this is what i'm
talking about
let's go into a little more detail okay
here it is
we have to distinguish between a buyer
who
receives without giving okay
and a buyer who receives and does give
we call this one capitalism if he gives
something in exchange
right it's capitalism and if he gave
something he's a seller
okay he gave some he's a seller okay
and if he receives something without
giving anything in exchange well we call
that communism you know the
government or whatever welfare so
socialism
you just receive you don't have to give
anything in return
you know uh uh uh
had that idea from or i think it was
marx uh
from each according to his capabilities
to each according to his needs
right well what if you only have one way
of flow of that
uh to each according to his needs
and you don't provide any of your
abilities either because there's no work
or maybe you're uh quadriplegic maybe
you cannot provide anything maybe you're
a veggie
and we want to keep you alive i don't
know why but we do
and because we keep you alive we just
give you we give you care
we give you food you know we give you
everything and you can't do anything
about it because you cannot
contribute to the global economy in any
way
so you're receiving okay you're only
receiving and we gotta factor that guy
and in the case of seller on the bottom
we have
a similar situation we have to
distinguish between the giver who
receives right and there's an exchange
there
we call that capitalism but the giver
who doesn't receive
well we typically refer to that as
communism
right socialism welfare state whatever
you want to call it and you've got all
these
names for it right and so
what i'm saying here why why is this
relevant in the context of the
extinction theory
what's relevant because i say that
we're becoming more and more okay
receivers who do not give okay
there will be more welfare people more
unemployed
people eventually and so we gotta
factor the language here we gotta say
well these people
are receivers do they buy yeah they buy
but they don't sell
okay that's my point and if you buy and
don't sell
you got to call i call him a buyer but
the
correct word is receiver he's a receiver
and right now we don't know where he got
all that stuff from
for all we know he got it from heaven
manages
you know falling down in in his hands or
in his lap
the only time we really have capitalism
is seller seller
then yeah someone gives and the other
one gives
okay but if it's a one-way flow
we call that communism okay and so
i want to distinguish the receiver from
the giver
okay because i'm saying uh
more and more people will become
receivers and fewer and fewer people
will become
givers okay that's that's the argument
okay moving on here uh
get another one here one fellow says
it could be that when basically now the
system breaks down meaning
extinction or approaching extinction the
uh
global economic collapse that's what
he's referring to here
it really is built back better okay
meaning less communist okay that last
part
is politics okay unless he's trying to
say something special you know there i
don't know but
this is like saying oh it's it might be
good thing to have like a world war
iii you know you raise the board start
all over again
okay will it be like that we raise the
board
uh can we come back okay and then he
says
fiat currency falls to zero
okay says all money goes to zero
then people begin using real money
golden
bitcoin so he thinks uh gold is real
money bitcoin is real money but he says
all the other stuff you know especially
dollars and so on that's
that's not money okay but i like his
last statement there he said
just because of currency and or
government
fails doesn't mean all trade ends
uh i tend to disagree
okay yeah the day that currency fails
including gold including bitcoin
and nobody should accept that anymore
because uh what are you gonna do with
bitcoin what are you gonna do with gold
what is gold gold is a rock
uh is uh limestone any better than gold
i mean you know i'll give you
limestone for your banana if you want
you know or your apple
if you'll give me your apple i'll give
you limestone a rock any rock you want
you want gold okay i'll give you a real
gold if you can do something with it
what are you going to do with it and
bitcoin bitcoin's a number in a computer
once we get the hackers in there you
know messing around with the
global internet uh even
bill gates and jeff bezos and all these
people will be
as rich as you are overnight
they just press one button all that all
those accounts go
wacko go out of you know so
yeah i mean the the issue is that if
government falls
if the global economy collapses
meaning money will be no more
all kinds of money will be no more the
only money
of any importance will be food and it
won't be money
because it will be the only thing of
value in that sense you can say it's
food
it's uh money but nobody will trade it
in which sense it's not money because
money is that which you trade it's what
you use
something of value that you trade that
you exchange
if you have something of value but you
don't trade it
it's known as food it's food it's known
as food after the
global collapse that's what it's called
okay so now
uh once the global economy collapses
there won't be any money okay
because that's the point the point of
the theory is saying there won't be any
money
we will not accept money we will not
accept any kind of money
for the whatever amount of food that you
have
because the only thing of value will be
food it's the only thing
keeping you alive you're not going to
trade the only thing that
has uh value which is what nourishes you
in real life for for what for gold for
bitcoin
uh and and just do the thought
experiment you and your buddy
you know you got shipwrecked or you know
you're marooned on an
island it's just you too and
um you know you ended up in this
different sides of the mountain and
you've got all this food that you were
able to get out of the ship
in a little boat and you came ashore and
now you got all this food
and your friend you know he got the
treasure chest
okay he's got all this gold diamonds
jewels
he comes over says joey uh
here i'll give you a whole bag of gold
just comes in here or you know ingot
of gold one kilogram of gold
i mean that's worth a lot and i'll give
it to you for
for that uh banana or for that apple
will you trade
[Laughter]
well if you do you're you're a sucker
you're you're
uh you got mental problems okay you
don't understand
no no when you're stuck in an island you
have no use for bitcoin
believe me okay another fellow says
even worse he says
self-sufficiency that's he he says that
you're going to do
see you have two two types of people one
is the
[Music]
survivor okay and the other one
is uh and that's the guy that goes out
on the mountain and with a gun
and a backpack and he's gonna do hunting
after everything collapses
okay and then you have the others uh
that plant the garden and they say i'm
gonna do some gardening okay
and i'm gonna grow my own potatoes and
my own tomatoes and everything
and i'll be okay after the collapse
well the big problem here is not whether
like he says here understand how to how
to do it that's that's not an issue
the issue is not how to do it which is
which is a problem obviously if you're a
city
guy you've never been in the farm well
you may not know how to plan you may not
know
about the season you may think banana
grows you know on trees or whatever you
know
so you may need some information that's
true
but i think it's irrelevant anyone who's
got a garden he'll be
run over you know at the last moment by
all people from the city
all these city folks that don't know
anything about farming
and they're just gonna go out there and
steal uh they're just gonna
it's not called stealing it's they're
just gonna eat
like a locust you know they're gonna
swarm all over your farm
uh if you've got any live
animals like chickens or pigs or
whatever they're gonna kill them and
slaughter them what are you gonna do
just shoot every person in town
uh thousands of them many of them with
guns
and then uh obviously they're gonna take
all your veggies from your garden
and if you're alone you haven't planted
very much
you know how many acres can one person
plant
and even if you have a tractor okay i
mean
one person how much can he plant and
then
assuming you plant a lot i don't know
several acres because you're
really good how do you patrol that
with your sixth shooter or whatever
you need a machine gun even that won't
help you you need a cabinet even that
won't have you'll need a nuke
to get rid of all the people they're
just gonna come in and eat
and then you have this little kid you
know eating you know a piece of your
corn
you're gonna grab your gun shoot him in
the head don't eat my corn
now so uh the problem's gonna be
security you have no 9-1-1
after the global collapse so this notion
that
we're going to survive and we're going
to restart the human race adam and eve
thing again it's never going to happen
once the whole world collapses more or
less you know they're going to be
pockets of people here and there that
survive i think they're
that's almost guaranteed but they're
just going to live out their lives
they're not going to be going out there
and saying oh let's start the whole
thing all over again
especially after we've wiped out all our
genetic diversity
we have no genetic diversity today
whatever
pockets survive you're going to have
this
you know this small group founders
effect
and from there from that wiped out
genetic diversity you know you have no
genetic diversity among you in that
little group that maybe three four five
six
seven ten people maybe you're going to
start
the human race again you're gonna have
children by the hundreds
assuming women don't forget what it was
all about
okay no and a woman would not put
herself
in that situation either because you
know you won't have all the niceties of
uh
hospitals and doctors and nurses tending
to you yeah
you're gonna have to have the baby out
there in a cave
so i don't know how many women will want
to do that fishy after
we've gotten used to the city life we
have all these
comforts we take for granted i'm not
sure that woman is
gonna go out there and say i'm gonna
have a baby maybe one might have
on planet earth but certainly we're not
gonna restart the race again the human
race again
okay um one vowel says
a little more closer to my subject which
is
the dinos and how they disappeared okay
and he says if the food pyramid that
inverts were the most critical and
numerous food chains
such as plankton okay which is the food
for the food for the food for many
might that not lead to a mass extinction
aha okay
would that not explain part of how the
sea creatures went extinct
when the big animals went under 65
million years ago
okay might not all of that be one
big food chain collapse that commenced
when the smaller sea
creatures died and spread up the chain
going up to reptiles large mammals
if uh any and even insects
okay uh yeah that is the theory i'm
proposing
okay this is what you
see this is just one food chain uh since
you talked about the seas
okay and here you see it okay
um this is more or less what the
seas look one one this is just one food
chain
in the seas okay this is at the end of
the cretaceous
okay and what you see here is uh
at the bottom of the food chain you have
the phytoplankton okay
and what is that well seaweed and uh
other um algae that
rely on the sun to grow into you know to
reproduce and all that stuff
and then they're preyed upon by the
herbivores of the sea the small
herbivores which are the
zoo plankton okay there's a zoo or zoo
plankton
and what they do they're gonna eat all
this stuff
and they're gonna live on it
okay so these are herbivores and some of
them are carnivores also within that
group
okay and they might attack one of the
herbivores
but then you have the bigger animals the
higher level you can say
someone talked about the higher uh
animals okay so we'll call these higher
animals they're just
higher on the food chain they can eat
someone below
and so they're going to eat some of the
zooplankton
both herbivores and carnivores
and then you have the big monsters like
the reptiles like the mosasaurs
and they fed on the ammonites you know
who were you know these
filter feeders and so on and
and you also have fish in between i
didn't put all the animals you know that
should have been in that picture i'm
just showing you a very small food chain
and that's more or less what it looked
like okay and so yeah
uh one of the issues that
we've verified okay through the layer of
rock
okay and you can look up some of these
uh papers
that have been written out there there's
several of these okay so it's not like
one paper out there that says it's
several of them it's like a consensus
among the
paleontologists that this is the
description of what they see in the rock
what do they see well they see that the
big
the major the the big ones you know the
big um
plankton were the ones that went away
at the kt boundary essentially some
uh went over the boundary and lasted a
few more years
but essentially what died out close to
the kt boundary
were the big uh for a minifra dynams
and so on these animals
and phytoplankton disappeared
essentially most of them and that was
the food that the ammonites depended
upon
and the moses are primarily fed
on uh ammonites and there were ammonites
all over the place ammonites are used as
a
an indicator fossil for
almost the entire uh life on earth they
look at that because they were so
numerous in every age
okay they were very numerous and you
know
they had hard shells so that survived to
a great extent
and so they're used as indicators okay
and yeah when they
so we know that uh the ammonites
disappeared at the kt boundary
and that's what the mosasaurs ate and
they disappeared at the kt boundary
and so the question is did they
disappear because an
asteroid hit the earth which is what the
uh reigning theory is out there
well you know that asteroid would not be
able to explain cell activity
and here you can explain cell activity
you know for that whole
food chain that you see there simply by
uh noting that the plankton that they
ate
also disappeared at the kt boundary
okay so that's that's the point there
okay
okay next issue is that
uh like i always like to say you have to
do
and if possible you know it's
recommended
you are urged to do this to do
extinction 101 before you do extinction
102
101 is animal extinction animals that
actually died in the past
so once you figure how they died how
they disappeared how they became extinct
maybe you can extrapolate that mechanism
demand and say well
which is extinction 102 and say well can
man
do anything about that same mechanism
and you know the person who just treats
it very superficially usually he says
man can do anything we can solve any
problem
we can look ahead our intelligence
allows us to look ahead
fix any problem that comes towards us
well there are certain things we can't
do we can't live forever
no matter what otherwise we would have
invented the machine that does it or the
drug or whatever the food
we can't have babies anymore they say
what
what do you mean yeah we can have babies
no we can't
we we're not having babies we're having
fewer and fewer babies so that lady at
the beginning of my talk here
uh didn't have to worry about that they
don't have to put a one child per family
or two child per family
um law
we're not having babies we're not having
baby babies because we moved to the
cities
and what takes over are density
dependent birth rates
so we're not having babies because
couples
in the city don't have babies cities are
no place
for a baby it was in the countries where
our great grandmothers you know and so
on
had 10 babies half of them died and five
continued living
no problem today we're not having babies
to begin with
we have one maybe in you know treat them
like uh
like a god you know is the only baby
you're gonna have you know so oh he
looks like me i'm gonna
and they're expensive and then you're
gonna you don't have time for them
anyways you get a babysitter to take
care of them because you got to go to
work and
so on and so forth so no we're not going
to have 10 babies anymore no woman's
going to do that
and so we're and partly because if
they're expensive and the culture in the
city develops in a given way
and that was inevitable that we moved
from the country to the city
the other one is that there's no room in
the city again room also in this sense
means economics
okay there's no economics in the city to
have babies
and then what are you going to have an
apartment that you can barely pay
the rent on you're going to have 10
babies in your apartment
so no babies the baby era is gone
we're not going to have babies anymore
uh you know one woman can have a baby
10 women will not have a baby that's the
issue it's a numbers issue okay
so no babies are out
and yeah just in case uh here's the
issue people should answer and which is
what this uh
fell who just made the last uh question
there the last common
address and that's um why did the
animals in the sea die at the same
time as the animals on land okay and if
you can figure that out
okay maybe have a clue to how
um the animals disappeared in the past
and whether that same mechanism whether
we humans can overcome that same
mechanism
okay okay let's move on to the lecture
today
on physics and we're going to be dealing
with entanglement
what the hell is entanglement does it
mean you're
tied up in knots i'm entangled
okay let's look for a definition okay
here we have the definition from the
wikipedia and this is what they say
quantum entanglement
is a physical phenomenon that occurs
when a
group of particles are generated
interact
or share spatial proximity in a way such
that the quantum state of each particle
of the group cannot be
described independently of the state of
the others
including when the particles are
separated by
a large distance so if you're going to
not explain you're going to be
describing okay very important
difference in those two words you're not
going to be talking about explanation
you're going to be talking about
describing and they're saying you cannot
describe
certain behaviors or properties of this
particle
without relating them to the group
that's the first part and the second
part is it doesn't matter how far
the nearest particle is to that other
particle it could be on the other side
of the universe
they are what is known as entangled they
are
somehow connected one particle
influences the other even if it's on the
other side of the universe
and so the only way you can uh describe
the behavior the particle the target
particle
is by relating it to all the other
particles or that are in the group and
the group is as big as you want to make
it
okay so it could be local it could be
bigger in a house it could be bigger in
the earth
you select how far you want to take that
okay
and again one of the issues there that
you have to keep in mind
that's where the notion of field comes
in also because you're going to give
a value at each point in space okay
that's the definition of field right
says uh if a pair of entangled particles
is generated
such that their total spin is known to
be zero
it doesn't it's not spinning i guess and
one i don't know why they say zero they
say it's not spinning
i think it's easier to say that okay and
one particle is found to have clockwise
spin
right so we're talking about spin right
atop right so they said no spin
spin we should have said what is
spin zero okay and one part it was fun
to have clockwise spin
on the first axis then the spin of the
other particle
measured on the same axis is found to be
counterclockwise
one spins clockwise the other one spins
counterclockwise
okay so they say that's a pair of
entangled particles
okay so you should get the notion here
that
what they're referring to is that when
when um
one particle spins you know just think
of two tops i guess you know
one top spins clockwise the other one
spins counterclockwise like when seen
from above okay
so you're seeing them i guess you know
straight ahead
from your eyes and you're seeing them
from top and so what happens
one is clockwise the other one is
counterclockwise and when the first top
you turn it around and turn it in the
opposite direction turn it
counterclockwise
the other one instantaneously goes
clockwise
and you say well maybe they're too close
together and blah blah blah no no
they're saying that one could be on the
moon the other one could be on earth
these tops and this one influences that
one
and quantum remember quantum deals with
discrete particles
so we're talking about discrete tops
here okay so this top
clockwise this one counterclockwise
one's on earth the other one's on the
moon
in fact uh brian greene illustrates that
in one of his uh programs
in one of his documentaries okay so
that's exactly what they mean okay so
keep this in mind okay okay uh
einstein good old let's bring him into
the show
1935 he uh called it spooky action at a
distance because how can that be
possible that
one that to describe one of the tops
right i have to
[Music]
have some notion of the other top
like that one's going to influence this
one
and i just said that's ridiculous and he
did say it that way because he didn't
want to offend
the copenhagen folks the copenhagen
interpretation
which was held by niels bohr and werner
heisenberg and
some others like born max warren okay
so he argued that the accepted
formulation of quantum mechanics must
therefore be incomplete
and i think it was his buddy podolski
they had the epr
uh einstein polovsky and rosen the three
guys who wrote this paper and it's
called epr to this day
uh the initials of each one of their
last names and i think it was podolski
who
leaked uh the notion that
einstein had when he published this
paper in 1935 he leaked it to the new
york times in new york times
uh ran in a little article on that and i
think
einstein was not very pleased with that
okay okay
uh so where did this uh
notion of entanglement start did it
start in 1935 with epr and
einstein for those heroes in the paper
that he wrote i'm going to
show it in a second now it starts here
it starts in 1927 about eight years
earlier
okay and it's at the fifth salvo
conference
in belgium and all these gurus of
mathematical physics not physicists but
mathematical physicists
meaning mathematicians meaning
mathematicians that's all they are they
just do equations
they met okay 1927 i think it was
october
november and um and here we have these
two great men of science
uh niels bohr and einstein and they had
a
big debate okay the debate was not about
epr einstein paulowski wrote an
experiment which is you know this
uh action at a distance without an a
mediator
okay no their their discussion was
about the slit experiment okay
and the slit experiment as some of you
know
uh looks more or less like this okay
here's einstein and niels bohr
and get it up here
in a second
there we go this is the einstein
experiment
he says look we shine uh monochromatic
light
okay through two slits and we see this
pattern
on the on the screen okay uh we don't
see just two holes we see
fringes okay and so einstein was trying
to show
niels bohr in this discussion that we
could measure that accurately
and uh so he he came up with his
argument and
what happened niels bohr he was
frightened because
this would destroy quantum mechanics if
you could measure that precisely
and so he thought about it one day i
think he came in the next day he said ha
ha i got you heine
and he says uh look uh
according to your own uh theory if um
if we shine a light at the
in this case the we can call them the uh
window sills of the other partitioner of
the uh
slits we sent light at the slits
okay and they hit the the balls and
photons right
they hit the window sills what happens
when as soon as the photon hits the
the window the window sills it's going
to move the entire
partition to some extent and here i'm
exaggerating but the point is that if
it moves then you cannot know the exact
position of the photons and of the waves
okay so uh with that
argument supposedly more came out of
that uh
meeting or the that argument it was
lasted a couple days
came out victorious he said look you
know as soon as you shoot a photon out
the windowsill it's going to move the
partition
slightly whatever amount just enough
that you do not know
the exact position of the particles okay
that was his argument
okay um
so where did these two gentlemen go
wrong
well they went wrong because they were
using this window sill there
okay and we're going to replace that
window sill now with a needle
okay and so now we have a different
situation
it turns out that you can do the slit
experiment without
you know using the slit the double slits
you can do it just by putting a needle
in front
and in that case if you put a needle now
they have
the the photons have nothing to bounce
again there is no window sill
against which to bounce and so the
photons should continue
straight and never make you know that
pattern
the explanation is wrong in other words
okay
so if we can do it with a needle okay
it destroys the slit double slit
version of of the slit experiment
we should call it the needle experiment
which by the way is much easier
um to do okay and here let me show you
okay uh i always use here's a needle
okay i stuck it to a little cork or
whatever i've got a
got a couple of these you know so take
them with me so we have
so you can see it better and you know i
just stick on
a needle in a cork you can do this at
home always in the presence of a uh
trained relativist okay so here you have
the needle
okay and you shine a laser okay
i'm gonna there's a laser i'm not gonna
shine the laser because it's very hard
to hit it
but you know you shine a light imagine
that's the laser
and you're gonna when you look at the
wall you're gonna see the fringes
you're gonna see the fringes with the
needle and the laser very simple
experiment
you don't have to break your head trying
to make a slid or measuring
the distance and any of that we don't
need any of that
just put a needle put a um a laser
pointer
uh shooting against it at the right
distance okay and you'll see the fringes
on the
wall no problem i've done the experiment
myself and just
don't take my word for it just do it and
so the question is
right now you know you don't have
anything the photons the alleged photons
have nothing to hit against
to bounce back inwards and so now we
have a problem
because now we can't use discrete
photons
and even if you use waves transverse
waves why would they curve
around the corner i mean we're not
talking about
water waves see they always simulate it
with water waves
the question is you know light is not
alleged to be water waves there are less
to be transverse waves okay
and transverse waves you know they just
go up and down and
sideways and they go in a direction
perpendicular to those two
directions okay the cross
and so why would they turn a corner i
mean with water waves yeah you can
simulate it but are we saying that light
is a water wave
like a waterway because if it's a
transverse wave there is no reason for
light to turn a corner which it does
okay and yeah so this is
this is where we have a problem under
the rope model it's a no-brainer
the slit experiments so i'd like to show
that you know in comparison
here you have um the lights turned off
and you have i only showed two atoms
there being connected
okay here i show two atoms again but
many many of the connections to
every atom on the wall or on the screen
and what you have is when you
have the light turned off okay there is
already
a connection between all the atoms okay
there's already a connection
but it's not turned on because the um
the wavelength is long and the frequency
is high is is low okay what happens when
you turn
the light on what you're really doing is
you're increasing the frequency meaning
you're making the goosebumps smaller the
wavelength is now shorter the frequency
in other words the number of
links is higher
and so now you bring it into the visible
range
and what happens is the atoms on the
side of the needle
are relaying that signal
from the flashlight to the atoms on the
wall
okay or on the screen okay that's what's
happening that's
under the rope model okay so we now have
an explanation
of physical interpretation that does not
involve
magic and all this other stuff that the
mathematicians have invented okay and
here you see what's happening actually
uh
with this uh with the ropes okay if
they're
in phase okay then uh and there you see
it on the bottom you see like blue on
top and red on the bottom
on both ropes that converts upon a given
point on the atom
well then you have constructive
interference and you have a bright light
because it's
pumping uh it's it's compelling the atom
on the wall and stimulating it's pumping
at a faster speed
okay and possibly even to a wider range
okay
maybe there's two phenomena going on in
there on the right hand side you see
destructive interference and that's that
they're offset you have the blue on top
and the red on the bottom
the threads right and the other one has
red on the top and blue on the bottom
and so they interfere they meet
at the same atom at the same place right
we're talking about gazillions of atoms
here i'm just looking at one here
okay they meet at the same place and the
signal they're receiving are
counter to each other and so
the atom does not get that stimulus okay
so it's not
pumping faster and because it's not
pumping faster
uh the wavelength is below the visible
range
okay so one has high frequency
short wavelength the other one has long
wavelength uh
and low frequency and that's how you can
tell the difference between
a bright spot and a dark spot the
fringes
that you see there so we have an
explanation for it and
uh the explanation really has been
around for a long time
it's based on waves okay
and you heard it those who did high
school physics know that
they explained this with waves what
we've done is simply remove the wave and
do it with
ropes because there is no physical
object called a
wave wave is a concept in fact if you
look at all these waves that they show
they're both uh
in dynamic and static uh you'll see that
they're just a bunch of vectors
vectors which are at 90 degrees to each
other to different heights
so anytime you look at a transverse wave
look very closely at what you're staring
at
what you're staring at is a bunch of
vectors
it's only mathematics that's what a wave
is there is no physical object called
the wave
okay uh in the ocean it's water
that's what's waving there's not a wave
that's waving it's a water that's waving
okay flag it's not known as a wave it's
known as a flag the flag is waving it's
not a wave that's waving and so on down
the line
and the same thing with light it's not a
wave that's waving
because there is no physical object
called a wave just a bunch of vectors
mathematical
uh vectors that's what they have values
and they put little arrows there and
they confuse you because you think
you're
looking at an object you're not okay so
keep that in mind always when you look
at one of those
be aware of what you're actually staring
at
okay um pull on the other side
give me a second here
okay uh so what have they done well
in order to try to explain the slit
experiment you know quantum really went
out of its way
because they couldn't explain so they
kept going into the lab and trying to do
different things
with with the um slit experiment
and they put mirrors and they put all
kinds of detectors they put
eyes then they removed the eye they said
don't observe and then they put the
observer and
they went through all this rigmarole
just to figure out
you know how light how mother nature's
doing this magic trick
and of course today they still don't
have an explanation for this
they don't have an explanation that it
can that you can rationalize okay
and you can see all the stuff that
they've done just to try to
uh see what's going on with a slit
experiment
and it's like uh mr feynman said richard
feynman
he said you know really the slit
experiment contains the only mystery
of quantum mechanics if they could
answer how
light does that magic trick well they
would know a lot
about light but they don't they keep
doing it with particles they keep doing
it with transverse waves which are not
physical objects and
every time you simulate it with either
one of those first they have a one-way
flow
okay one-way flow of particles one-way
flow of
uh waves whatever those are right and
then they cannot explain it with that
either
and they keep putting all these
obstacles to try to see if they can
detect it and
they finally reach the conclusion that
every time you put an obstacle and
detect it
you're influencing the experiment the
observer is
compelling light to behave in a given
way and then you cannot observe what
you're trying to observe
because you moved it that's the issue
okay and so um
let's continue here this is uh einstein
he came up in 1935
and he wrote with pogolsky and rosen can
quantum mechanical description of
physical reality be considered complete
he was challenging niels bohr and his
copenhagen interpretation saying look
there are hidden variables that we're
not aware of
and that doesn't mean that you know that
we can never
measure okay we can never measure we
should be able to measure
all we need to do is find out what all
those hidden variables are all those
ghosts that we're not
particularly aware of okay and
and a few months later in 1936
niels bohr answered him and criticizing
this
epr this uh einstein paulowski erosion
argument and but they didn't have the
technology at the time to
so-called prove in the lab one way or
the other
uh who was right and were they trying to
prove
an explanation uh no
they don't have an explanation they
don't have any explanations
in quantum mechanics none not one okay
they don't have a community they have
descriptions
okay and so what they were arguing about
were
descriptions they're saying look the
description of quantum mechanics
is that it's a wave until it becomes a
particle
and it becomes a particle when you
measure it at that point the
wave function collapses to a point and
that's why you measure a point
before that before you take your
detector or whatever your
probe uh light behaves as a wave as a
i guess a field they would call it many
ways we don't know what's going on there
the cat is both dead and alive you know
and it
only collapses to a point to
something detectable to something
classical you could say
okay when you measure
at that point it collapses einstein
didn't like that he says you're saying
that
we have this f fuzzy world out there
before we measure
that we cannot know anything about and
that's why it became
a probabilistic theory
there was a probability of where the
photon or the electron could be
at okay but they didn't know exactly
until they measure and when they measure
so it's too late because now the
observer
interfered with the experiment and that
or
you could say it entangled the
experiment
in other words at that point there is an
interference with a particle you want to
measure whether it be
be it a photon or an electron now it's
interacting
because there's always distance between
particles right now it's interacting
with whatever
first atom is close by it's interacting
when it interacts
means it's uh entangled with it
it now deals with its environment with a
group
of particles not only with a particle
that you want to measure
that's how entanglement started getting
into this well einstein
and his successors people like um
uh who is it um
boom yeah uh he um
he he came around the same time a little
later than einstein obviously but
bong came up with this hidden variables
notion as well he said look
there are hidden variables and all we
need to do is design an experiment and
la la la but we should be able to figure
out
how all this is put together and it was
a fellow named
john bell and he came a math magician
obviously you know what else can you
find in mathematics
okay and he came up with uh an ex an
idea
okay and really before that
we had first the experiment and the
experiment that they came up with
an idea how they could test this is
uh with the what what is known today is
the alice and bob
experiments what they do with thought
experiments they have alice in one place
and she measures
something clockwise and bob is on the
other side he measures something
counterclockwise and when they wanted to
see if there was any possibility
that you could detect uh by just
measuring by
bar by alice measuring something they
could tell
what bob would see there without
measuring
okay and some people explain it like you
know if you had a heads or tails
okay well you can either have heads or
tails
okay and you can't have both you do have
both but
only one side can show up at a time or
you can have
uh like one thousands out there uh
two gloves you know have left handed
glove and a right-handed glove
and you put the two gloves in different
boxes one glove here and the other one
over there
well you know if you open your box and
your you got a left hand glove
well you know the other one is a right
hand glove
okay and now again that's a description
it doesn't tell me why the other glove
is right-handed
okay you cannot explain why the other
glove is
right-handed okay and this is the
problem so the analogy is not quite
right in fact
not right at all it's a bad analogy
a much better analogy is the rope okay
because you know one side
can go counterclockwise and the other
side had better go clockwise to the
viewer from the other side i'll show
that in a second
but anyways um this is what they show
where here we have alice on one side of
the world and we have bob on the other
and they're saying if alice spins
clockwise well
uh bob must of necessity spin
counterclockwise
and vice versa alice now you know you
turn around she goes counterclockwise
well then bob will go clockwise
okay so this was the experiment that
they designed
out there okay or it was a thought
experiment okay
and they designed this and they said
well unfortunately we don't have a way
of testing it
at the quantum level at the photon at
the electron
level so it's like a mood issue yes a
thought experiment
and that doesn't go beyond that turns
out one foul this uh
fellow uh john uh
what's his name uh sorry
uh his name is john bell
he came up there and he came up with uh
an equation
and he came up with a number he came up
with a calculation
and he says imagine a
pair production photons one atom shoots
two photons in opposite
directions okay he says well he came up
with this notion of the
bell's inequality as it's known today he
says
he looked at all the possibilities and
he says well there's only 33
possibility that both photons will be
detected or go
through uh the um
the polarizers that are at either end
okay so you put two polarizers like you
see at the bottom there
see have two sensors okay whatever that
polarizer means to you
you put two sensors okay and here you
detect it uh
uh you can say clockwise spin clockwise
here you detect it
spin counterclockwise and they know
that's the case
always okay because they've done the
experiment many times
in different ways uh ever more uh
precisely and so bill
just thought he says look there's only
so many possibilities
and he came up with a number he says
look it's got to be 33 percent
or more of the times that we should
have the polarizer detecting the photons
going through it
okay if you put some interference in
there like
uh a polarizer uh uh
something like uh calcium carbonate uh
uh a slab of this material that allows
light to go in certain directions that
polarizes light
okay but anyways if if light goes
through
in both cases okay there's only 33
uh possibilities of that happening if
you do the calculations right
turns out when they did the actual
experiment it was greater than 25
percent
so there was an inequality there because
you know they said hold it
this is what our calculations show but
this is what we see in the lab
it's a greater than 25 percent
probability
and that's essentially how they
eliminated you know this
hidden variables at least in the minds
of
most mathematicians i'm sure that as
always there's someone still out there
saying that uh
it hasn't been proven to them or
whatever okay again proof this is a
question of
personal taste uh how you grew up how
how you think uh proof is in the eye of
the beholder we should never use proof
in science okay okay uh so what happened
well one fellow did
the experiment quite accurately his name
was
ellen aspect a french guy
and he went out there and he really
measured this very precisely
and again confirmed first that epr does
happen
okay confirmed that i guess he
his experiment is known uh the most
because
it was done very precisely and second he
he agreed with bell that it eliminated
uh all these hidden variables there are
no hidden variables according to
the standard version of quantum
mechanics
they continue to insist primarily in the
copenhagen interpretation meaning that
there's this complementarity light is
both a particle and a wave
it travels as a wave and uh
it begins and ends its journey as a
particle
that's the official version today okay
and again uh ellen aspects
essentially did away with um with hidden
variables
okay so what's the status today of this
thing well
um this is brian green and he'll tell it
to you in his own
words he says spooky action at a
distance does indeed happen
meaning they cannot explain it they have
no explanation of how two discrete
particles i like to show
this way let me get rid of brian here
for a second sorry brian i'm
gonna get you out of here bye uh
you have two particles okay
and they're not connected okay so how
does this particle affect this one
if this one is turning right it's
turning clockwise
why does this one turn counterclockwise
how does this one affect that one
and if this one if you turn this one
counterclockwise
how does this one now turn clockwise
what i mean if there's nothing in
between that well yeah then it's called
spooky action at a distance
in fact you have uh one fellow his name
is
nick lewson he has his uh show on
youtube and what this fellow says is
that quantum is not magic
well it is magic if you cannot explain
it dear lucid
okay curly i call him because he's looks
like curly and talks like
curly but anyways uh the three stooges
right
um if you cannot explain it it is known
as magic
i mean you know you get a pygmy he can
get some iron filings
and get a magnet and play around with it
all day
so he can do it and he can say it does
that piece of metal does pick up the
iron filings
it does happen yeah
and now tell me how it does it why does
it do it
what's the mechanism and that's where
these people go wrong see because they
can tell you
epr does happen entanglement does happen
one particle
does influence the other one okay
that's that's so far it's magic because
so far you haven't explained how
it does it and you can't explain it with
discrete particles
because you got to put ghosts in there
and that's essentially where we have
today we have you know all these people
with hidden variables and so on
here you have you know all these ghosts
and goblins and witches that
you know move through the experiment and
that's what's happening
they don't have an explanation how you
know a particle can shoot
two photons in opposite directions and
one photon
influences the other and the only way
you can explain is like i said before
uh with a rope okay then yeah in other
words
an elongated object you can use a chain
if you want but you need some kind of
elegated object in other words
this is what i'm saying here you know a
rope
okay so from your end you know again
my from my end it's going uh
counterclockwise hopefully from your end
that
that end there is moving clockwise
in your eyes and if i move this one in
the opposite direction
mine is now moving clockwise and yours
had better be moving counterclockwise
okay so you can see how easy it was all
these years
and yeah you need an extended entity
assuming my fists are
atoms then you can explain how you know
one atom influences the other clockwise
or counterclockwise
without the rope you know you have only
the two
atoms there how does one atom influence
the other if they're all discrete
entities they're not
contoured by anything or connected in
any way
how do you do entanglement without an
elongated entity
between them that's what you got to
explain otherwise you don't have an
explanation you're putting ghosts in
that same region
and goblins and angels okay
so here are my conclusions okay let's
get down to the conclusions
okay what are conclusions entanglement
arose when the quantum mathematicians
could not explain the slit experiment
that's where it all started
1927 maybe for eight years even beyond
that really
they discussed the slit experiment like
uh feynman said
uh it's really the only mystery
okay of quantum mechanics if you cannot
explain
if you can explain it you've got it all
solved and right now
no one has explained the slit experiment
in a rational manner
in the last hundred years with quantum
without quantum with
general relativity with string theory
put it all there they have not been able
to explain it
okay and so some mathematicians proposed
that there were hidden
variables okay and boom was primarily
the big the guy who fought most for that
notion and bell's inequality essentially
convinced
the the you know the congregation
the mathematical congregation okay
uh they proved as they call it in
mathematics
they proved that uh could be uh
the case okay that there were no hidden
variables
okay so aspects uh epr experiment okay
first uh convince them that yeah in in
fact
epr does happen entanglement does happen
and
second confirmed in the minds of most
mathematicians
that there are no hidden variables
okay entanglement starts out where it
began
it continues to mean ignorance
okay so we should call it quantum
ignorance and my coral area is
no experiment meaning c touch okay
experiment you're going to go to the lab
you're going to see or touch something
right
now experiment and no equation will ever
identify the invisible
intangible mediators that mother nature
uses to do light
gravity magnetism electricity atomic
behavior etc
okay so that's the end of the story for
entanglement entanglement entanglement
according to
quantum mechanics is magic because
unless you have an explanation you
are talking magic and mr nick lucid who
boasts that
quantum is not magic well he uses a wave
and there is no physical object called a
wave
so as soon as he introduces the wave
he's already
we take the microphone away from him
okay he can't talk any further until he
explains
what a wave is then of course he's got
to explain also the
atom why the electron doesn't
spontaneously fly away from the atom
what holds it there in other words again
we have this entanglement and the
entanglement in this case is between the
electron
and the proton they're entangled
okay great that's a description you're
just saying that it's
it it isn't tangled it stays there
it goes around an orbit uh within a
certain
uh plus or minus region no problem
that's a description
tell me why what causes the electron
first not to fly away and second not to
fall
towards a proton that's what you got to
explain you can't explain that you don't
have an atom
and the same goes for
light if if you cannot explain why
uh these this photon over there is
entangled with this one over here if you
cannot explain that physically if you
cannot give me a physical interpretation
you cannot give me a cause a mechanism
you're you don't have a theory
you're not even a scientist scientist
someone who can explain
rationally
okay let's move on to uh some of the
questions commons people made this week
okay here's one
well it says can you demonstrate
okay can you demonstrate more clearly
how the diagram of
whatever 15.03 depicts the mechanism of
destructive
interference okay uh
i thought it was clear sometimes i
wonder about these files because
i mean if the guy went to high school
maybe even college i don't know
uh he should have seen that all this is
explained
explained with waves
they talk about interference with waves
with
transverse waves so they show that if
the two waves
are in phase it is constructive
interference
and if the two waves are out of phase
that's destructive interference
okay so all we do is replace
the nonsense called wave there is no
entity called wave you've got to find
out what is waving
and we're saying it's a rope and so with
the rope it's it's the same thing
so i'm not inventing anything new i'm
just saying that the wave is replaced
by a rope all these years they've been
confusing what they call a wave
and uh it was really a rope all these
years and so here's the wave version
okay you can see
constructive interference there on the
left hand side
you have destructive interference on the
right hand side
and you see the bright bands and the
dark bands what part did you not
understand
okay and now we're gonna do it with the
rope and the same thing okay
and here we see you know light coming
out of the laser
okay it goes through the slits we don't
need the slit we can put a needle but
in this case we put the slits because it
really doesn't matter
and the ropes on the top are connected
and i want you to look very closely at
what
at the last two links close to
the right hand side uh that atom there
that's on the
screen okay and what you see is that uh
they're both
in phase and in the bottom one they're
both out of phase y
because there's a different angle in the
two
beams coming from the slits you see the
angle is different
and the bottom one and the top one i
should have labeled those
but the point here is that in one case
you got a blue against red
and the other one you have blue against
blue or red against red
okay so that's all it is uh
nothing fancy it's just what we've known
already for many years
and here again i show what it is you
have your blue with blue
it's a constructive interference and in
that case you have
a bright band and then you have blue
against red or
or you know you have it's better to say
it blue on the top and red on the bottom
red on the top and
blue on the bottom and now they're out
of phase and so now it's
destructive interference so that's all
we're saying here really you know i mean
i'm not sure what part you don't
understand okay
okay let me get rid of this here
okay uh another fellow says i think it's
the same fellow he says polarization
okay says uh i hope you haven't
forgotten the explanation of light
polarization okay let's find out
what is this polarization okay here i
showed it the other day and
uh what you have is a uh
i'm gonna look at the top one first top
when you have a beam coming in at a
polarizer could be again typical
material is calcium carbonate it's a
slab okay
you put it in front okay and yeah and
it's uh
the the issue with carb calcium
carbonate
is that the molecules are
oriented okay the rows of molecules are
oriented and so
[Music]
they could be oriented for example
vertically
okay if you turn the slab around now
they're all
going horizontally so if you put two
slabs one right behind the other and
they're both vertical like you see there
the green one and the
purple one there right if you shine a
light well
uh what what happens under the rope
model okay
is that the atom one atom that i show
there just one atom we're talking about
gazillions of atom in real life but here
i'm shooting
looking at only one atom that's
connected to one atom
in the flashlight on your laser pointer
or whatever
one atom in the slab the first one and
one atom in the second one
but they're all aligned in other words
they're all vertical
okay so what happens uh when you turn on
the
laser pointer uh
one atom again we're gonna deal with one
atom that's complicated enough with one
atom okay
uh one rope is connected to the other
atom and it's at a certain frequency in
other words
certain wave length now it's visible
light it's at a frequency that
within the visible range okay and that
atom
relays that same signal to the atom
behind it which is also
aligned in the same way vertically okay
and that one relays it to the one on the
screen which is also well that one
doesn't really matter just
uh stimulates the atom on the screen
period
and it's lit as you can see it's lit
okay
the one on the bottom what happened well
now we turned
over turn 90 degrees the second slab
could be the first one it doesn't matter
you turn the second slab of calcium
carbonate
and you turn it at 90 degrees to the
first one so now one
now the molecules of that second slab
the green one
are horizontal the first one is vertical
the second one is horizontal
what happened what happened just the two
atoms the same two atoms that we had
before well now you can see the location
of that atom is different
uh and i drew the rope there
even though the rope remember goes
behind
the first slab but i drew it just so you
can see the
direction of the rope how it goes down
and then up
okay so something's happened to that
specific
atom that pair of specific atoms
that were connected first in a single
direct line directly to the
screen or to the wall and now you turned
it around
and now they're not on the same axis
okay
and i showed that the other day
let me get rid of this
oh let me get this into we're going to
be
dealing polarization here so you know uh
this is my little gadget just to show
the mechanism okay put it in reverse
here okay so here you have
the ropes okay here that's what i'm
showing okay
so here you have the ropes okay you can
see what i've done here
we have two slabs okay really three i've
got two of them together
you have two slabs okay and you have the
ropes that interconnect
four atoms okay what happens when you
turn one of them around
well you can see that the atoms are no
longer on the same axis they were here
on the same axis very straight
directly you know the light is coming
from my left or from my right
when i turn one of them around it
they're no longer
the those specific atoms are no longer
on the same axis
so the beam is extinguished you do not
get
relaying of the signal along the rope
to the one on the wall okay so that's
that's the mechanism okay but there's
another mechanism going on it's got to
do
with the slit experiment
and that's that you know
when you turn it around all the ropes
that are connected only within the
system let alone the ropes that cross
crisscross the universe
or that come from the sun and all that
stuff we're talking only about the ropes
that interconnect the slabs and the
laser pointer and the screen that's it
let's just look at those ropes okay when
you turn
one of the slabs around you're also
torquing
the rope at a different and you already
gave it a quarter turn
all the ropes so not only don't you have
relaying in a straight ahead forward
manner because you turn one of these
slabs at 90 degrees horizontally
you also have twisted the ropes every
one of the ropes like
you know if you have it like this right
it's not the same thing as to have it
like this you know
you're twisting it like that you're
twisting the rope also a quarter
you know 90 degrees so you have all
these effects
so just to understand just to understand
the um linear
polarization let alone a circular
polarized light but just a
straightforward
um linear polarization is a monster
okay so all i can urge you is to
look at that first okay and let me show
you a little more let's go a little
deeper here
because i want to show you something
else here okay uh this is
from my book okay the rope hypothesis is
downloadable it's free okay and this is
around i think
page 135 or there about so it's towards
the end of the book
and there you see the three situations
okay
the first one on the top okay shows that
you have
the ropes in a north-south direction and
they're all
in a north-south direction because the
slabs are vertical
okay in the middle center group
there now we're going to rotate the
second slab
into the east-west direction
well what happens you because you
rotated 90 degrees right
so now uh the the
the row of uh molecules that make up the
slab
they're no longer vertical they're
horizontal and i'll call it east
west so what happens look at what
happens at the rope as soon as it
touches each one of those atoms well in
one case it was blue on top and red on
the bottom and the other one is the
other way around
okay and so what are they going to send
to
the screen well remember we're talking
about gazillions of atoms here
but some of them are going to be uh
red on the top and blue on the bottom
the other ones are going to be blue on
the top and red on the bottom
and so you won't you're not going to get
any light not only because you've
twisted the rope but also because the
atoms are now no longer in the same
direction
and they're not relaying the signal to
the wall in the same
act on the same axis what happens when
you put a
45 degree slab between those
well you start reestablishing the beam
because now you gave the
ropes a quarter turn okay
so all these effects are have to be
analyzed in detail
and it's a monster just just to look at
this alone let alone you know uh
if it's a circularly polarized light
just to look at linear just that's
that's a monster on it that's a
whole course okay okay but
let's go a little deeper just so you see
why that's the case okay we're going to
go into a deeper why
here cause a mechanism okay and here it
is
and that's also in the book so it's for
free look around
i think it's page 135 131 something like
that
you have calcium calcium carbonate okay
and you have
uh these little men well they're not
little men okay that's what the molecule
looks like okay calcium carbonate three
caco3 okay looks like that
that's more or less the aspect of that
molecule
if you were at a man and went down there
and looked at it
so it looks like a little a gingerbread
man okay
that's what they look like so the first
one front view
completely towards the left okay you're
looking at it straight ahead you're
looking at there's your eye
okay you're looking at straight ahead
and we're only going to look at a couple
ropes here we're not going to look at
the gazillions of ropes crisscrossing
just two
of these molecules okay there's a lot of
a lot of ropes
crisscrossing there alone okay but we're
just going to look at the main ones that
we're interested just to show you the
mechanism
right now you're looking straight ahead
you're looking at one in front the other
one behind
these are the atom these are the
molecules that belong to each one of the
slabs you got the first slab and the
second slab behind it
okay now you're going to rotate that's
the second
set there okay slightly to the right of
that you're going to rotate one of these
slabs
what you're doing is rotating the
molecule and now you can see what's
happening to the ropes
you know they don't get tangled remember
it's just that they're not on the same
axis
anymore that's why you extinguish the
beam okay
and then on the right hand side on the
right-hand side of the black line
dividing line there
you see again but this time you're
seeing it from the side you're looking
at the same molecules but now you're
looking at them from the side you're
looking at side by side
you have the first slab there in the
second slab okay and these are the
molecules that comprise
these slabs and you can see what you're
doing when you're
rotating the second slab okay
the atoms are no longer aligned they're
not on the same
axis okay so this is what's happening
in there okay when you extinguish the
beam why a polarizer
works okay that's the mechanism we are
proposing
and yeah it's a monster just to
understand this alone because you got to
look at what's happening to the ropes
and remember uh calcium carbonate has
calcium which has many atoms essentially
many hydrogen
atoms comprising calcium you have many i
have
eight comprising
carbon okay eight ropes because you got
to think of
every hydrogen atom that comprises
carbon which is eight of them
each one has a rope okay and so when
when you look at this you're looking at
many ropes just for one molecule
let alone from the fact that you know a
slab of this stuff has gazillions of
molecules let alone atoms and all these
ropes are there
so you've got a three-dimensional
spider's web very
very uh dense spider web and you're
going to rotate this thing so
you know you got to try to visualize
this and it's not easy
not easy at all the best thing is to try
with one atom at a time which is what i
did here
and try to visualize that and see
understand the mechanism
then if you want to beat your brains out
go ahead and put more ropes in there and
twist it around and see what happens
okay but i think uh the important part
is to understand the theory and the
theory is the mechanism
an explanation of the mechanism
okay one fellow says info theory
okay he says please make a lecture about
information theory
he went to a site and i guess they gave
him a lot of slack
about uh information theory and saying
that you know i guess some religious
folks they say that dna
is uh information from god that god made
that
message and send it to us and so on and
so he
he didn't have really good arguments to
counteract that and so he said
he went there and he says information
can only be produced by intelli by an
intelligent being i don't know
i don't think that was his statement i
think that's one of the statements he
got
from this site that's what they hit him
with and then god created the
information
in the dna okay so this is what they hit
him with so he says you know do
do a lecture on this so that
he can have some arguments or you know
to counteract these people
okay i dealt with information in the
past a couple months ago at least
but let me show you right up front this
is from my other book why god doesn't
exist
okay and i'm not going to read all that
i just want you to focus on one part
there
that came out of that book says dna
contains no information
in itself because information is what an
extrinsic
observer derives okay
dna is not a message dna
is not information people
uh it's the mathematicians have confused
all this stuff completely they talk
about
sending information receiving
information they treat information like
a physical object
information is what you get
out of anything okay there is no
dna is not information dna is a molecule
it's a
it's just a bunch of atoms put together
that's all dna
is now you look at dna
and you say oh i understand this or i
understand and i can describe that
that's information
information was someone gets out of it
you don't send information
you receive information so to speak
information is only on the receiving end
and the mathematicians never learn that
so they talk about sending information
and you know and uh and how fast
information travels and
shows you what kind of idiots they are
they are truly idiots
idiots meaning people with big ideas
ideas okay
and we call them idiots and so so
uh dna or anything you read a book the
book is not information
information is what you get out of it
you're understanding that's information
okay so let's get that right information
is only on the receiving
end you never send information you
always
receive information so let's get that
part straight
but yeah one of these days maybe i'll
give another lecture on information
i don't have it in my things to do right
now i've got other uh
issues there with uh quantum mechanics
and uh
so right now i'm doing a series really
on quantum mechanics
and no there is no information in
quantum mechanics because
they have not learned anything from
quantum they cannot explain anything so
they have no information
okay they keep transferring uh the
information never receiving it
okay another foul says i have a small
problem with the rope theory aha well
it's
a rope high hypothesis um i don't really
have a name for the theory i call it the
thread theory but
even that you know thread is is a
hypothesis it's an
object it's a thing but that's how i
divided it maybe someone
smarter than me comes up with a better
name for the theory okay which is the
explanation of the mechanisms rope is an
object
it's a hypothesis an assumption okay
okay of gravity after learning about
lagrange
points these lagrange points are
locations where the balance of
gravitational pull allows satellites to
remain stationary
with respect to the earth's sun system
without them wandering ahead or behind
relative to the earth's
orbit okay what i want to know is how
l2 and l3 okay he he gave me a
description of
l1 through l5 okay and he wants to know
l2 and l3
are possible if the ropes that connect
the satellite
go through both the earth and the sun
before getting to the satellite
in other words well let me just continue
reading this
i thought gravity is a function of the
number of independent ropes it is
wood ropes going through the sun and the
earth make them no longer
independent and only pull as much as the
near one okay
uh more or less yes uh yes yes yes and
uh let's let's see if we can make sense
of this
what he's asking essentially is you have
the earth and the sun
okay earth and sun and here you have the
satellite
and the earth remember earth goes around
and so the satellite is sometimes
between the earth and the sun
and sometimes at the other side and
sometimes it's on
on the sides okay so if you could say
it's uh parallel
to the earth with respect to the sun so
we have all the these three situation
in front behind and to the side okay
those are the three situations
and the first thing we have to just
clarify
okay that there are gazillions of ropes
crisscrossing our solar system
we call it the cosmic background
radiation it's all those vibrations
okay gazillions of ropes are just
sending light and all this uh
fuzziness out there which they claim
fills all of space it does and it's just
ropes
within space each one each rope is very
well delineated okay
uh specified but you have gazillions of
ropes i wrote i
just put it there in criss-crossing in
different direction to show that
our solar system is crisscrossed by
gazillions of ropes that
gum come from the other side of the
universe and go past us
some die at the sun some die at the
earth others go directly
past us okay so we have all these robes
just crisscrossing in our
solar system okay that's the first thing
just keep that in mind
and there we have the three locations
for the sun from for the
earth and that bright little spot near
the earth
right at the bottom and on the side
there those are
we'll call that the satellite that beige
bright beige
and keep in mind we also have mercury
close to the sun
we have venus there okay and those two
are also connected to
everything there but they're too far
away okay
uh it's very important to know that
they're very far away okay
distance here remember newton's uh
equation
distance is of the essence here okay
okay so this is what they look like okay
here we have the three locations for the
earth
we have the satellite there okay and in
one situation
uh which is the one on the lower left
there
um we have the um what is it the
satellite is between the sun and the
earth
and the second position there uh it's to
the
side of the earth and then the other one
it's behind the earth
okay and so we have these ropes coming
from the sun
in one case going right through the
satellite to the earth and the other one
you have
ropes coming separate you know some to
the earth something of the
satellite and then the other one uh the
ropes go through the earth and
go to the atoms that comprise the
satellite
okay so those are the three situations
okay that's essentially what he wants to
know what is the difference so how do
you handle this okay
okay and here let's look at a simpler
version here
we have um what i call the bird speak
okay this is important because it's a
function of distance
square of the distance in case of light
but
it's a function of distance it's an
inverse function of distance the farther
away you are from an
object the more the ropes come together
and form you could call a single coaxial
they're almost on the same axis
so gravitationally they have no they're
weak
they don't pull the only way you can get
the
that quick acceleration in fact you get
acceleration
is when you're within the bird's beak
okay
and the sun has a long bird's beak
compared to the earth year
has a small bird's beak and here uh i
just show
the difference in bird speak but the
important part is that between the ends
of the two birds beak and and the birds
beat just continue extending extending
extending but
for the most part okay uh we we have
what what i call the linear regime most
of it is
essentially a single coaxial until it
comes to our
area and a lot of people have problem
visualizing that because they say well
hold it from the edge of the earth
to the edge of the sun yeah it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter because those
are very few of us that's why i didn't
draw them
okay the important ones are the ones are
where the
big coaxial is at and that's through the
center okay
so you do have ropes connecting edge to
edge from the sun to the earth
but in comparison to the ones that come
in the main axis
you know they're almost irrelevant and
again
uh remember the sun is very far away in
fact we
see the sun about the same size as the
moon which is close by and much smaller
why do they look the same pretty much in
size because
one is very far away and again the
moon exerts a little more influence or
just about
maybe the same amount of influence as
the sun i'd say the moon is
a little more powerful than the sun as
far as gravitationally
because it's the distance makes the
difference it's just much closer by
so here is
the final version of that you see the
two little electron electrons you see
the two uh satellites
okay and one satellite's
in front and the other one is behind
okay
and what's the issue here the issue here
is first the earth exerts
a much more powerful influence over the
satellite because the birds be
let's assume the satellite is just at
the edge
of the bird speak of the earth okay it's
far enough away
where the bird speak uh towards the sun
you know
of the ropes connecting us to the sun
that's where
the birds beat ends and that's where we
put the satellite
same the one on the other side okay and
so
what happens there is you're talking
about the satellite and only the ropes
that are connecting the atoms
that comprise the satellite to the atoms
that comprise the sun
well it really doesn't matter that much
because remember the earth's
bird's beak dies right there very far
away
and then what you have is essentially a
single coaxial
uh of the atoms of the sun
that are connected to the atoms that
comprise the satellite
okay so yeah even the saddle i have a
tiny
bird speak there okay for that matter
but the point here is that
you know most of that uh the the sun
exerts almost
no influence gravitationally over
you over the satellite over anything
okay the only thing the sun does really
is prevent the earth from flying away
is it because it's pulling on it
gravitationally
you could say it is uh any
more or less like like this this
does the my finger which in this case
would be the sun
pull on the ball gravitationally
but it doesn't have to it just has to be
equal in other words the rotation of the
earth around the sun
has to equal the strength
of pull you could say of this
uh rope that connects us of all the
ropes that connect us
but if the if the earth just goes back
and forth slightly because you know
uh the earth also goes the sun goes also
around the milky way so
it swings it uh keplerian like you know
uh
sometimes the earth is a little farther
away sometimes it's closer by you know
it's not a perfect circle
but if you string this thing around okay
uh you're not talking you're not talking
about gravity per se what you're talking
about is that
the sun is just preventing the earth
from flying away
it is in other words the earth if
if the earth were not orbiting the sun
it would drift towards the
the sun eventually it would fall
into the sun but as long as it's going
around it just maintains
essentially a static position with a
slight variation
only because the sun is itself is going
around the milky way
and swinging the earth around itself
while it does so
other than that you know what you have
is this long coaxial
and it just maintains it just prevents
the earth from flying away that's
that's all it does there is no real
gravitational
pull okay if the earth were not rotate
you know going around the sun rotating
uh
it would gradually fall towards the sun
only because now you don't have this
uh centrifugal force okay other than
that
the only purpose of the coaxial is just
to keep the earth in place
and it does the same thing to the little
satellite it doesn't affect the
satellite gravitationally in any
significant way
any more than the moon does now all
these objects
the er well the earth to begin with
really but
jupiter venus all these planets exert
some influence very tiny influence over
that satellite
and the satellite does not um
always keep its exact distance from the
earth
the satellite does move a little bit as
well because of all these influences
maybe they're not measurable maybe it's
very slight but the
the satellite does not maintain always
the same exact distance
okay and again it's because all these
celestial objects
influence it but very little you know
the uh gravity
the gravity that you can get from uh
jupiter
even from the moon which is closer by is
is um is very tiny in fact uh the moon
does
affect for example the tides according
to newton and that's very possible
okay uh but again uh you know it's not
it's not like uh it affects you
you know it doesn't affect the tides to
the point where
it pulls the water off the earth okay
so yeah the moon affects the tides but
its influence
is very light and the same thing with a
satellite
all the celestial objects in the solar
system
affect our satellite but it's as much as
they affect you
uh which is like astrology which people
say that
the stars us so much especially when
we're born
that it gives us certain tendencies and
so on well
go study astrology and then you'll
figure out if it's true or not
okay folks uh i'll see you on um
wednesday and i'm gonna have ons with me
and we're gonna do some
question and answers real time so get
your questions ready and
throw all the rotten tomatoes you can at
our faces
we'll see you then i'll see you on
wednesday bye